>> Laura: LAST NIGHT I SHOWED
YOU HOW THE LEFT ATE UP ANOTHER
POTENTIAL RACIAL SITUATION,
ENDED UP BEING A RACIAL HOAX WE
THINK.
THIS ONE FROM GEORGIA STATE
LAWMAKER ERICA THOMAS.
AFTER THEY ARE DISHONEST SPIN
FELL APART WHEN THOMAS' ALLEGED
HARASSER TURNED OUT TO BE A
CUBAN DEMOCRAT, WHO DOESN'T LIKE
TRUMP, PART OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
RESISTANCE, IT TURNS OUT THOMAS
CHANGED HER STORY.
YESTERDAY THOMAS CHANGED HER
STORY BACK AGAIN.
IF YOU ARE CONFUSED, SO ARE WE.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT IN ANY WAY
BY BACKTRACKING ON MY STATEMENT
OR MY RETRACTING ANYTHING I
SAID, WHEN HE SAID AND MADE
REFERENCE TO GO BACK TO WHERE
YOU CAME FROM, HE SAID IT RIGHT
AFTER HE SAID NO, I KNOW YOU
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE IGNORANT.
AFTER THAT, HE KEPT BERATING ME
AND HARASSING ME, THAT'S WHEN I
SAID, AND YOU CAN SEE FROM ONE
THAT CAMERAS WILL BE PUT OUT FOR
PUBLIC, I POINTED TO THE DOOR
AND AFTER HE SAID GO BACK,
I SAID YOU GO BACK.
>> Laura: NONE OF THIS SHOULD
COME AS ANY SURPRISE, GIVEN
THOMAS' HISTORY.
SHE WANTS AN IRONICALLY CALLED
HERSELF JUSSIE SMOLLETT
#BiggestFan.
A YEAR AGO THOMAS PORTRAYED
ANOTHER'S LIFE, THIS TIME
REPORTEDLY AT THE HANDS OF HOTEL
EMPLOYEES AT THE WESTERN AFTER
THE WAITRESS ASKED THE     CAUCA
THE WAITRESS ASKED THE     CAUCI
THE WAITRESS ASKED THE     CAUCN
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF ME FOR
THEIR ORDER AND SKIPPED OVER ME.
MINUTES LATER, THE POOL BOY
ASKED ME FOR MY ROOM KEY.
THIS CANNOT BE REAL RIGHT NOW.
I AM A GUEST TOO, RIGHT?
IS THIS TRUE?
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROVE THAT'S KIND
OF THE POINT.
THOMAS IS A MEMBER BUT WE CALL
GENERATION G, OR THE GRIEVANCE
GENERATION.
THEY ARE THE PRODUCT OF DECADES
OF LEFTIST CONTROL OF OUR
SCHOOLS, OUR AND ATTAIN THE
INDUSTRY, AND THEIR BREEDING
CULTURE OF RESENTMENT AND ENVY,
BASICALLY A SOCIETY OF VICTIMS
AND THE VICTIMS, NO MATTER WHAT,
ARE ALWAYS RIGHT.
HERE TO DISCUSS, CANDACE OWENS,
FORMER DNC COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR LUIS MIRANDA.
CANDACE, THOMAS ISN'T COMPLETELY
TO BLAME.
THERE'S THAT DEMOCRAT AND MEDIA
COMPLEX THAT ALL TOO OFTEN
REWARDS THIS KIND OF GRIEVANCE
CULTURE.
GENERATION Z, WE HEAR ABOUT
GENERATION X AND THERE'S
GRIEVANCE THAT'S UNPROVABLE.
>> IN MANY WAYS, SHE'S A VICTIM
OF THE CULTURE, AND I'VE SAYS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AD NAUSEAM
AND WATCHES JUST THAT
VICTIMHOOD AS ALMOST BECOME A
MENTAL PLAGUE ON BLACK
AMERICANS.
THE WORD RACISM IS BEING SO
OVERUSED THAT SOCIETIES BECOME
DESENSITIZED TO IT AND REACTION
CAN EVEN RECOGNIZE IT WHEN IT
EXISTS.
WE THINK EVERYTHING IS RACIST.
THINGS THAT USED TO BE NORMAL
CONFLICTS.
GETTING CUT OFF WHILE DRIVING,
HAVING A BAD CORRESPONDENCE IN A
GROCERY STORE.
YOU SHOULD JUST SHRUG IT OFF AND
MOVE ON WITH YOUR DAY.
NOW PEOPLE ARE CRYING AND MAKING
VIDEOS AND PLEADING ON FACEBOOK
TO SAY LOOK WHAT I EXPERIENCED
TODAY.
IT'S SAD FOR HER, BUT I ALSO
THINK AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER,
IT'S SOMETHING BIGGER THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CULTURE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BEFORE IT
GOES TOO FAR.
>> Laura: LOUISE, THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO SHE EXCUSED,
SEEMS LIKE HE REALLY DOESN'T
LIKE TRUMP.
HE'S A DEMOCRAT, CUBAN, NOT A
WHITE MAN.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> HE'S EASILY THE WORST PERSON
IN THE STORY AND HE LOOKS AT A
PREGNANT WOMAN AND DECIDES TO
INSULT HER AND BY VARIOUS OWN
ADMISSION CALLS HER A LAZY SOP.
PROBABLY A TINGE OF RACISM
THERE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE WOULD CALL
HER LAZY OB IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
SOME OF THAT.
THE MEDIA OVER PLATED.
THERE IS WAY TOO MUCH RACIAL
TENSION, IF HE DID TELL HER TO
GO BACK, IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE SHE
MAY HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD IT BASED
ON THE INCREDIBLE TENSIONS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE AND THE DISCOURSE
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW ABOUT THESE
RACIST THINK SADDAM TRUMP USES
FOR
POLITICAL GAINS.
SO THAT'S DEFINITELY THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM.
I THINK THE PERSON IN THE STORY,
THIS MAN --
>> Laura: HE'S A JERK.
HOW MANY TIMES DO ALL OF US IN
THE COURSE OF MAYBE A WEEK HAVE
SOMETHING HAPPEN WHERE SOMEONE
IS SLIGHTING US OR SOMEONE
SAYING SOMETHING, CUTTING OFF --
HAPPEN TO ME TODAY.
NOT ONLY CUTTING YOU OFF BUT
CUTTING ME OFF WITH A
MILLIMETER.
THREE KIDS IN THE CAR.
MILLIMETER AWAY FROM ME.
AND THEN FLIPS ME THE BIRD.
WHY ARE YOU FLIPPING ME THE BUR
BURN?
>> CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
CAN YOU INSULT A BLACK PERSON
WITHOUT BEING A RACIST?
THAT'S A QUESTION.
>> WHEN HE WENT WITH "LAZY," >>
ARE YOU SAYING THAT BLACK PEOPLE
ARE LAZY QUESTION REQUIRED IS
THE WORD LAZY -- I'VE NEVER BEEN
CALLED LAZY IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
WHY DOES THE WORD LAZY ME -- I'M
ASKING THE QUESTION.
I ASKED YOUR QUESTION.
HE SAID LAZY MAKES YOU THINK OF
BLACK PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
>> IT'S A COMMON RACIST TROPE.
>> THAT'S NOT A COMMON RACIST
TROPE FOR BLACK PEOPLE.
I'VE NEVER HEARD THAT.
I THINK HE'S A JERK.
I THINK HE IS AN ABSOLUTE JERK.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> YOUR CALLING BLACK PEOPLE
LAZY.
>> IT'S A TYPICAL RACIST --
IT'S NOT.
LAZY IS A WORD.
>> Laura: WE'VE GOT TO STOP.
IT'S GETTING TOO HOT.
I THINK THIS DOES GO TO THE
POINT THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE BAD DAYS AND PEOPLE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO MAKE MISTAKES.
HE PROBABLY MADE A MISTAKE WAS
REALLY RUDE TO HER AND HE
ADMITTED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN --
MAY BE IS, THAT HE IS IN.
NO ONE CAN KNOW.
THE SECOND AN ALLEGATION GOES ON
FACEBOOK LOVE, WHOEVER MAKES IT
-- I DON'T CARE IF IT'S A
CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL OR
SOMEONE IN BETWEEN, IT'S
INSTANTLY PICKED UP IF IT IS
VALIDATING A PROGRESSIVE
WORLDVIEW.
INSTANTLY PICKED UP.
CONGRESSMAN GOES ON TV.
PUNDITS WEIGHING IN.
THIS IS WHAT TRUMP CAUSE.
I THINK HE SEEMED TO BE SAYING
GO BACK TO THE OTHER AISLE.
NOW GO BACK TO THE OTHER ISLANDS
GO BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY.
SHE CHANGED HER STORY.
>> A LOT OF THE DISCUSSION THEN
WE HAVE ON THIS VERY SHOW OUR
AGREEMENTS CULTURE IN AND OF
ITSELF, JUST FROM THE OTHER
PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE AN AND CULTURE --
YOU EITHER HAVE A GRIEVANCE ON
THE SIDE OR THAT SIDE IN THE END
OF THE DAY, I THINK OF
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING'S CALL,
YOU CAN'T DRIVE OUT DARKNESS
WITH DARKNESS.
YOU HAVE TO DRIVE IT OUT WITH
LIGHT.
WE HAVE NOT ATTACK EACH OTHER
THIS WAY WITH THESE COMPETITIONS
BECOME NORMAL.
THE POLICE COMPETITION,
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Laura: THE LACK OF RESPECT
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
ANGLE ALTERNATES, THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
OBAMA YEARS, BEFORE OBAMA, BUSH,
REAGAN, GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE LATE 1960s.
YOU GO BACK AND YOU WANT THAT
RAW FOOTAGE OF THE POLICE VERSUS
THE PROTESTERS, THERE WERE BAD
ACTORS ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT IN
THE DNC.
NOT VERY LONG AGO.
THAT'S WHEN IT ALL KIND OF
BEGAN.
THE DISRESPECT CUTS ACROSS MANY
LEVELS OF OUR SOCIETY.
IN A KIND OF AN SUB WHERE PEOPLE
FEEL AFRAID.
A LOT OF PEOPLE I KNOW ARE
AFRAID TO SAY ANYTHING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SHARE A
THOUGHT BECAUSE SOMEONE WILL
TAKE IT THE WRONG WAY.
THEY ARE FREE TO SAY THEIR
OPINION.
IT IS ALSO ANOTHER GOOD PLACE TO
BE.
CANDACE, ALSO WE HAVE
BREAKING NEWS.
CANDACE GAVE US THIS NEWS.
SORRY, I FORGOT.
YOU ARE BLOCKED TONIGHT.
MAYBE AOC THAT YOU'VE
DISRESPECTED HER.
YOU DISRESPECTED AOC?
HOW DARE YOU DO THAT?
>> I CALLED HER AN INTELLECTUAL
COWARD BECAUSE SHE SAYS A LOT OF
THINGS AND THROWS A LOT OF
INSULTS AND YET SHE WILL NOT
DEBATE ANYBODY.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO DEBATE
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE AND I THINK YOU ACTUALLY
BELIEVE WHAT YOU BELIEVE, YOU BE
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION AND DIALOGUE TO GET
TO THE CORE OF WHOSE IDEAS ARE
BETTER.
I DON'T BELIEVE SHE BELIEVES
ANYTHING THAT SHE SAYS, BEYOND
GETTING CLICKS AND RETWEETS.
>> Laura: I DISAGREE.
I THINK SHE BELIEVES IT.
>> I DON'T.
WHY NOT SHOW UP AND HAVE A
DEBATE?
>> Laura: MAYBE SHE'S NOT VERY
COMFORTABLE IN DEBATES BUT I
THINK SHE --
>> SHE CALLS EVERYONE RACIST.
>> Laura: UNFORTUNATELY THAT
KIND OF ENDS THE CONVERSATION.
>> IT DOES COME INSTANTLY.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CALL
SOMEBODY LAZY, JUST SAY AWFUL
THINGS, BEING A BAD MOOD.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH AOC BUT I
MIGHT BLOCK YOU AFTER THIS
CONVERSATION.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
THE REALITY IS THE DEBATE HAS
GOTTEN TOO COURSE AND WE NEED TO
CHANGE IT AND I THINK DEMOCRATS
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP IN NOVEMBER OF NEXT
YEAR, WE CAN'T FALL INTO THE
SAME TYPE OF RHETORIC THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO FIGHT ON THE